and now tonight a disturbing story at
100 College in New York City where
crazed Professor held the knife to a New
York Post reporter's neck a machete take
a look at the video obtained by the New
York Post look at this
let's let's get out of here you can't do
that
now the reporter went to her apartment
in the Bronx for an interview following
her Outburst directed at a pro-life
group on campus take a look
you're not educated
next I mean you know we're talking about
abortions this is violent you're
tripping my students oh I'm sorry about
that no you're not I mean you can't even
have one baby so you don't even know
what that is
now Hunter College released a statement
condemning her actions and noting that
she has been fired we did reach out to
both the professor and her Union we did
not get a response as a reminder the New
York Post and Fox News share common
ownership here with reaction the victim
of this machete Outburst New York Post
reporter uh Reuben fentanus with us uh
Reuben you seem pretty cool considering
you had a uh machete at your neck thanks
for joining us tell us what happened
pleasure well uh it's it's as it's laid
out in the video photography we just
wanted to speak to this woman
um we thought uh we we might have a
chance given that uh she's obviously
passionate about her beliefs and maybe
if we showed up to her door she'd be
willing to to grant us an interview we
we you know in my career I've knocked on
ten thousand doors you know hoping for
interviews and once in a while you got
one and I thought this might work out uh
but I got a a bit of a surprise uh when
when uh she opened the door this was a
first for me uh uh she uh first verbally
threatened uh to to chop us up with the
machete and then proceeded to come uh
out of apartment brandishing the blade
and press it and pressing it against the
side of my neck uh for about a second uh
and and then she I guess realized she
was being recorded and went back inside
are you gonna press charges
uh I I have yet to figure that out I'm
I'm uh I'm in discussions about what I'm
going to do next I I haven't figured out
why would why would that why would that
be an issue for you
you know I because to be honest I this
is my first time ever
being in a situation where I've been
asked whether or not I would ever press
I've never pressed charges before or
even asked so I'm still sort of wrapping
my head around all of this
um that being said um you know
I I have to sort of you know talk to
police and see what my my bed and talk
to the company and see what my best uh
Avenue here is all right Reuben thank
God you're okay and thank you Brave
reporting on your part we'll follow the
story thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else